vous avez récemment interpellé le
ministre de l'économie français bruno le
maire pour obtenir des réponses car vous
dénoncez une décision du tribunal
d'arbitrage de la banque mondiale
décision qui condamne donc un on l'a dit
un l'équateur à à verser plus de 400
millions de dollars à une filiale de la
société pétrolière franco britannique
perenco en vertu d'un accord entre la
france et les cloîtres et l'équateur
expliquez-nous et bonsoir merci pour les
maths invitation oui le messieurs les
maires la france et contre les paradis
fiscaux on a vu les pros non seulement
avec le groupe des sept pays récemment
et bien et perenco n'est pas une
entreprise les françaises ont dansé et
cassis les traités était protégée
investissement légitime non pas des
manipulations corporatif dire
milliardaire que monsieur pérol a
profité du périgord c'est une situation
qui est en croix est un abuse de traiter
et l'équateur ne doit repayer pas cet
argent parce que et on est en crise est
très grave par la pandémie et rendent
montre que la situation est indéniable
comme jeudi dans le tweet
justement vous le dit hein c'est cette
question de paradis fiscal qui vous pose
un problème et vous écrivez aussi à
l'entreprise ne peut donc pas se
prévaloir du traité bilatéral
d'investissement entre l'équateur et la
france c'est bien ça ouais c'est entre
tech est signée entre paris c'est quitte
au pain avec les bahamas alors est ce
qu'un ceccaci et c'est un cadre
tweetie shopping etc comment ça
s'appelle dans la littérature dans les
pratiques de manipulation corporatif
pour abuser les traités et des
protections d'investissement et ses
traités sont néocoloniaux néocolonial et
parce que ils ont le plus de droits pour
les corporations que pour les êtres
humains
alors on croit que c'est en abuse et la
situation pour le peuple équatorien est
vraiment grave et les gouvernants doit
et revoir cette position est pas payé
cet argent pour perenco il a
suffisamment d éléments pour annuler et
l'arbitrage alors andré sarazin
rappelons que c'est le gouvernement des
manuels maquereau en plus qui a placé
les bahamas sur la liste noire des
paradis fiscaux c'était en janvier 2020
et qu'est-ce qui vous chante au fond le
plus dans cette affaire mais je crois
que c'est une décision correcte et
placer les pas ramadan une liste noire
des paradis fiscal et c'est la même
chose en equateur on doit penser que si
l'équateur on va payer c'était 400
millions de dollars à perenco bahamas et
cet argent va va pas rentrer en france
et les peuples frères français souvent
vont pas bénéficier et de cet argent
alors c'est une situation que paris se
quittent audois et doivent et parler
comme verser pour trouver une solution
et qui élimine les abusent de tri
d'e-shopping des entreprises comme le
preco